tétouan mat
framboisine qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
terminé avec tir il fini je suis parti
de chez lui en prenant toutes mes
affaires entre spa dehors merci c'est
gentil
merci je voulais pas dérangé tu manges
pas du tout promis je resterai pas
longtemps je donnerai son pic lac à oui
non mais en fait le clic accès aussi mon
lien à bombay les séparent à cheval et à
l'hôtel je te dérange non non non
resterai ce n'est pas grave je vais
dormir sur une chaise
t'es sûr oui oui ok c'est sympa je me
demandais est ce que tu aurais du
shampoing et du démêlant non bah oui
c'est embêtant ça parce que moi j'aime
bien prendre une douche avant l'hymne
coucher mais par contre s'il veut il ya
une boutique qui ferment tard au coin
des rues
c'est vrai tu ira chercher pour moi tu
veux que j'aille oui non pardon je crois
qu'ils me proposaient pas ce que tu
avais vu que j'avais mes grosses valises
à défaire oui bah oui non mais non mais
je vais y aller parce que tu as mangé
des des trucs à acheter donc eh bien
merci tu es trop chou à excuse moi est
ce que tu pourrais aussi me prendre des
tampons parce que si je reste plusieurs
jours chez toi on ne sait jamais
monseigneur j'ai luc star que vous
n'entendez on ne devrait pas accepter de
se laisser expulser du château de cette
manière vous le pouvez accepter cet exil
monseigneur arrêter de regarder ce
tableau mais elle m'a tout pris
elle a pris tout l'appartement à la même
prix que les claques il ya moyen de
reprendre tout ce qui est à nous ou
peut-être même plus il est à vous ce
clic clac c'est pas elle qui s'est tapé
les retours à samedi après midi ce cas
échéant qu'angoula vous avez raison elle
va payer ses dettes
ici c'est chez moi j'irais pas t'acheter
des tampons d'accord mais de toute façon
là j'en ai pas besoin
il le clic clac on le partage
martien de trois potes de toi
savait déjà équipé votre territoire
seigneur que voulez vous de plus votre
coeur conquérir lover escaut mec
ce type
les heureux